[Music]
it was Jesus 11 months ago when I shot
an episode of the show hit show on
Showtime billions and I met this man and
I'm like hey man if you're ever in Los
Angeles you want to promote anything
come on the show and he said I will and
now you are here promoting Dan Soder son
of a Gary new stand-up special on HBO
HBO now HBO go HBO and the man the whole
thing shot at the Bowery Ballroom back
in October now coming to your television
set Saturday at 10:00 Eastern Time a man
who plays methey on billions and so much
more Dan Soder good man thanks for
having me rich it's so funny to be here
because I remember that day of filming
yes I was with Sam Morril who's a
fantastic stand-up comedian and one of
my good friends and he was in the
episode yes and we talked to you briefly
we just had a quick moment you know
backstage talk to you and then we run
around the corner and did like the I
have so many questions I asked him like
he gotta be cool that he got a role in
Laveen we're making fun of me the day
before we filmed yeah that scene yeah he
did a training montage and Deontay
Wilder was doing their due in the locker
room scene yeah dollar bill and in the
steep Ennio teach and I did our locker
room scene yes I'm a huge boxing fan and
I love Deontay Wilder and it's cool to
be on set of billions because I know
compliment and lavine well enough that
they know when I'm freaking out
yeah and they're like you dork like
hello Wilder I mean it's a Coppola and
Levine who write and create wonders also
I mean they've got so it's they're
amazing through the most immensely
talented people I've ever been around
and that's just par for the course like
working on billions yeah you're just
around people where you're like hey I'm
also a fan of short your target
impossible I mean exactly it like David
Costabile who plays wags is I would
argue one of the greatest actors of our
generation
I'd agree and you'll be talking to about
stuff and I'll be like you know it's
like episode of the why you were in the
wire you're just like talking
I'm sort of breaking manner in breaking
bass Lincoln yeah that was you - just
like bringing up stuff for ya oh man but
me I met Deontay Wilder and my first
thought was oh my god yeah who in the
world would get in the ring with this
guy yeah and then a few months ago we
had Tyson Fury sitting in that chair
yeah and I'm like how the hell did that
referee even survive getting in between
these two guys who talk about just like
one of those old-school Godzilla movies
where it's like Mechagodzilla
they should make Wilder and fury fight
in a small scale so all their boxing
it's also like knocking down small
buildings right I mean this is huge
Meo Cheech was no slouch - I mean used
some of huge the craziest thing about
steep Meo touches one of the nicest
human beings I've ever met in my life
and then I watch that Daniel Cormier
fight and you're like well I don't know
this steep unbelievable and that was the
coolest thing about that entire day of
us filming that I guess you could call
it a boxing match this was all the
individual people that were there just
how cool everyone it was just a fun day
to be on set and then also I don't know
if you know this but some of the people
milling around were just billionaires
they were actual billionaires I did not
know that like the guy that shorted
Enron yes like sitting while we were
talking to you Sam and I was like three
seats away from us this is an extra just
watching he's in the episode where they
can they go to him sitting ringside and
David Levine was like you know who that
guy is right and I was like no he's like
okay what other tips do you have good
job how did you get involved with
billions I met Brian Koppelman he did he
did a stand-up for a while and he was
Appleman did yeah for like 18 months he
was doing it huh and he was just in the
scene he was just doing open mics and
that kind of stuff and I met Brian and
we became friends and I didn't really
know that he was a screenwriter when you
meet
people doing stand-up people all the
time are like I'm a screenwriter you
sure are buddy comedians we're at an
open mic in compliment is like you have
a screenwriter and like pure buddy and
then he was like yeah I gotta go to LA
for work I wrote a movie and I was like
what movies right he's like Ocean's
thirteen and I was like my first movie I
wrote with my partner David was rounders
and I was like yeah but then I jokingly
said no man I met I thought he was like
a construction worker like that's like
the energy he carries right and then I
jokingly told him like right after that
I was like hey let's just act like I
thought you're a construction worker so
because that's more comfortable right
and then I think he as he got back into
screenwriting and directing he kind of
was like interested to keep tabs on me
cuz you know I was just going through
the New York comedy scene and doing
different stuff like when I got my first
TV credit no nine on live at Gotham and
Comedy Central he's like how'd it go
he's just always this kind of like this
peripheral figure mmm-hmm and then you'd
have me audition for stuff you but I
can't come in an audition because I know
you want to be in stuff and so on
audition and fail and then I started
auditioning and then finally after years
we were gonna kind of do a show Levine
Koppelman and I we were talking about
ideas for maybe a pilot and then they're
like hey we're gonna go write this thing
with aaron ross sorkin about the finance
world and then they came back and like
hey it's a show it's gonna be a pilot on
showtime come in for it and I auditioned
for the pilot did you know that Paul
Giamatti was involved with I found out
through the audition process that it was
Paul Giamatti and then it was Damian
Lewis
and then it was maggie siff and Malin
Akerman and and then you start learning
that it's okay it's okay
but it got to that point where you're
like wait what am i auditioning for yeah
I think I should be on this do you know
who I am I'm a waiter at a Mexican
restaurant right and then finally they
Showtime like me and they brought me
back and eventually you know they were
like I don't think we can even have a
run off you can do a one-off in the
pilot or we can write you a roll if we
go to series but the way they said it I
was like you guys not think you're gonna
go to
Cirie's yeah I know but this this team I
mean that and it's so amazing you know
for Lakers team being like I don't know
if we're gonna go to the playoffs you're
like oh cool you mean when you added
Malone and Payton and you're not sure
gonna go to the class
alright so they came through with it and
you know they're like hey season one we
have about five episodes for you you're
gonna play one of the you know finance
bros kind of in the pit and I was like
and Murphy was born and it's been an
unbelievable it's been cool to you know
get on Team Mason and I saw the ax cab I
have this mug you know that you're
slowly trolling me no it's okay it's all
I have if I got a Mason Taylor Mason cap
mug I would have enough to what do I
have to Double Down syndrome ace cap
sweatshirt and mug okay see if you're
real friendly it's been an unbelievable
kind of thing to grow and watch the show
become huge right and great and season
five is gonna be we're filming season
five now and it's unbelievable okay so
it's gonna be do you know what the
ending is for season five right no I
even keep it from you MERS no kidding
I've heard rumors they don't tell us
anything they gave us episode by episode
that's it
yeah and then okay so we have guesses
okay Daniel okay Isaac who plays Ben Kim
and Kelly Aucoin yeah well have like
guesses like what do you think and now
that you know if you saw the end of
spoiler alert if you saw the end of
season four yeah Mason capitals folded
back in acts cast yes sir now we're all
back together and under the same roof
and that's just a lot of fun now we got
Dan Soder again we'll talk about his
stand-up special son of a Gary in a
second if I'm not mistaken the Nuggets
and Blazers were in a playoff series
everything west yeah they were in the
semifinals right and then so Kelly in
the episode aired
Kelly Aucoin is as you know he's been on
the show he's a die-hard blazer fan and
you're from Aurora Colorado right in
Colorado but my dad was a Bay Area
transplant okay and so I was raised
49ers San Francisco Giants push the
Warriors on me but then in 1991 my dad
moved back to San Francisco my mom lived
in Denver and finally I had this moment
of self-discovery in 1991 and that when
the Warriors dealt Tim Hardaway to the
heat mm-hmm I was like I I'm if there's
no Run TMC you're out
right now I'm gonna be a Denver Nuggets
fan I need a Denver team so who was your
guy I mean I love Linda Ellis
growing up lafon zoe ellis and then
matumbo and that whole Mahmoud Abdul or
I move team yeah loved him
him and matumbo took out the Sonics
right it was the Sonics it was the
eighth one but I said 1994 that's when
he's holding the ball yeah right and
then we got smacked by the Jazz the Jazz
were like cool way to win eighth seed
buried us but then you know what I love
about the Blazers Nuggets rivalry right
now yeah is who was the who was the
Western Player of the Week Carmelo
Anthony it's amazing we might just have
to see a Blazers Nuggets where Melo has
to come back in fact to Denver and he
broke our heart more than any athlete I
think in my life is gone ah the Montana
to the Kansas City trade I kind of
understood as a kid but Melo just being
like I don't want to be here
hurt as a Nuggets fan you're like come
on man read a good team in oh nine right
so Western Conference Finals so that
that'll be a fun if that plays out that
way he's been it's been fine like his
first game was less than but again the
guy's been you could you could say he's
rusty he's a big melody won the title of
course but I got to break the news to
Kelly Aucoin who's a giant Blazers fan
yeah that the Blazers got mellow I was
like you got our old boy Melo he's like
no I'll tell you where it was four
billion fans we were in between scenes
and he was sitting in Spiros office we
were all sitting around and I walked
into Spiros his office and I was like
Blazers got Melo he's like I was more
upset because I'm like yes took our line
guy is amazing by the way it sounds like
that could have been in episode looks
great is they put a lot of stuff in the
show that's kind of true to life right
so like they have Murphy as a 49er fan I
had that 49er mouthguard and then you
see it in the boxing episode I have
right cuz you've got to be out of your
mind right now right this is real this
is real though I can't believe Oh
business of like are they real are they
for real they are they're absolutely for
real I've been very lucky because one of
my childhood friends
who I grew up with is the run game
coordinator for the 49ers Michael
McDaniel and he's been a part of Kyle
he's worked with Kyle in Atlanta and in
Washington and it's not just any run
game here this is a serious like bad
we're gonna hit you in the mouth this is
what we do type run game it just fills
me with joy because Mike and I will talk
and he'll call me and I'll that we went
to a game last year my friend Chad and I
went to the 49ers Lions game and Mike
called us as we're driving to the game
and he's like you guys want to know what
the first play of the game is he goes he
goes if the Lions flex left and then put
seven in the box it's a right side gash
to Breda and Breda took it 65 yards
watch that watch that game back it was
the first play of the Lions Niners game
Wow and he and we're in the stands that
is it flex we're go like this grab at
each other so it's been not only are the
49ers my favorite team of all time my
favorite sports franchise mmm but having
like a friend like that that I know and
just kind of you know I've met Kyle
several times and we're at Mike's
wedding together and it was like that
kind of thing we're like man come on and
I love that defense that Roberts all the
defense's Niner fans kept being like
another D lineman I know right another D
line well guess what guess what yeah
another D line that's what you need yeah
that's what you need and the two
quarterbacks that we had a problem with
you know Lamar and Ross we're those are
the ones you're gonna have problems with
cuz they are just so good at extending
plays it's it's it's not exclusive to
the 49ers example although both of the
guys that you supposedly had problems
with and you know everybody does both
games came down to a field goal so you
never know you never know and I'm so
excited we know the non offense is a
sports fan you grab one thing like like
a parrot to yell back after a loss yeah
either if it's a call or a play right
and that the only thing I could come up
with after the loss of the Ravens on
Sunday was like just to boost field
goals were undefeated yes just like my
pair that was my parent thought run
lecture two field goals don't under feed
it but the Saints this week in New
Orleans is
scary yeah but I said man if the 49ers
the Green Bay Baltimore New Orleans run
I said if the Niners could win two out
of three I would argue that were than
one of the best teams in of know now
well I think I think even if you lose in
New Orleans yeah plus we play Baltimore
in Baltimore in the rain was real good
son asked the Dallas Cowboys the last
team they want to see if they finally
scratch and claw and get the four seed
who they want to see in the opening
weekend the last team that's a possible
five seed that they'd want to see all
right that's it's the San Francisco
49ers and they would not stutter or TLC
on well I mean the Seahawks they beat
last year sure in the playoffs they
would have send that building so they
can even despite the Seahawks being
better this year I'm just saying the
last one they'd want to see you the
49ers sports you know smart lot I would
like to see the Niners be the one or the
two seed to get that week course rest of
that but if it's gonna be cowboys Niners
o minor fan please and you just want to
send Alice I mean I know you weren't you
work with Ervin and mooch you know you
know that that was like man that rivalry
in the 90s was one of my favorite things
Oh baby
and then I know if we could do a revenge
to her and get the Cowboys mm-hm and
then go get the Seahawks in the playoffs
and then go get the Ravens in the Super
Bowl I'm Way okay we're all in on that
before I let you go why is it called Dan
Soder son of a Gary which is your
stand-up special this Saturday at 10:00
Eastern yeah well I I do some jokes
about my dad in it but I have a radio
show on Sirius XM called the bonfire
with big Jay oakerson monday through
thursday 6 to 8 p.m. on Comedy Central
radio and we kind of joking we both have
deadbeat dads named Gary and so one of
our joking side titles was we called
ourselves sons of Gary that was like our
biker name okay and then I had to do the
Fringe Festival and Edinboro is like
what do you wanna call it I was like I
guess son of a Gary and they're like
alright and then when they came to the
special what I wanted to call the HBO
special was buttmunch but they wouldn't
let me cause you know what
to send it anyway really and I went yeah
and they sent it and they're like we
can't did you say we can't dance owner's
son of a Gary 10:00 Eastern and Pacific
this Saturday exclusively on HBO and
they're all their platforms tickets
available Dan Soder com4 upcoming tour
dates in Boston mid-january San Diego
and Los Angeles as well as San Francisco
in February and so on and so forth when
you're back here in LA you got to come
back
absolutely I'm glad that we met we I'm
glad that we worked together it was a
lovely day on set as well a lot of good
work done that day Dan Soder on Twitter
and Instagram can't wait for the next
episode of billions and next season of
billions as well for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
under red TV for free on be our live or
download the Rich Eisen show app